in space people may not be able to hear
you scream but on earth people can
definitely hear you moan with
frustration Neil Blomkamp's alien 5 may
have the nukes the knives and the sharp
sticks but it definitely doesn't have a
release date I'm Simon and this is your
bug hunting news update the status of
alien 5 has been uncertain for several
months the direct sequel to the ongoing
sci-fi horror franchise was originally
set for a 20-17 release with district 9s
neill blomkamp directing but the
decision of ridley scott to move forward
with his sequel to 2012's prometheus as
well as giving it the title alien
covenant meant that Blomkamp's film was
put on hold late last year however star
Sigourney Weaver has revealed that she
still believes the movie will happen
aggressive comix reports the during a
Q&A for tech giant vmware weaver was
asked about whether the project was
actually happening well I think it is
Ridley Arsenal not to make our alien
until after prometheus 2 Scott wanted
his movie to shoot and be released first
but it's an amazing script and Neil and
I are really excited about doing it
we're doing other things until we can
get going on that I'd be really
surprised if we didn't do it because
it's such a great script and we love
working together so it's just going to
take a little bit longer to get out to
you but it'll be worth the wait if it
happens both Weaver and her aliens
co-star Michael buying or expected to
return for the movie last year Blomkamp
released various pieces of concept art
featuring both actors plus images of a
pulse rifle design intended for the
movie alien covenant is currently
shooting in Australia and New Zealand
last year Scott revealed that the film
would feature all the versions of the
franchise's famous creatures he told The
Wrap there was always this discussion is
alien the character the Beast played out
or not will have them all egg facehugger
chestburster then the big boy I think
maybe we can go another round or two
alien covenant is set for release on
october six 2017 are you excited for
more alien action or after prometheus if
you just got xenomorph xenophobia let me
know in the comments or come find me on
twitter
i'm at the Jagan or thanks for watching
and for all your entertainment news keep
it gamespot